so this game was played almost exactly a
month ago i think it was played
june 24th i'm recording this on july
25th
it was played as part of the meltwater
champions tour
it's called the gold money asian rapid
tournament and it features the one and
only
daniel dubov the super grand master
against haui fan
the top active female player in the
world
and dubov unleashed the stafford gambit
and one with it which just brings me so
much joy
and duboff is probably the highest rated
player
ever to have played the staffer gambit
in a serious competition of course the
stafford has been played by grand
masters
in like online bullet chests but to play
the stafford in a serious competitive
event where there's money on the line
really goes to show that perhaps even
top level players have to be prepared
for such an opening
so before we jump into the game i do
want to thank
the sponsor of today's video is
skillshare
thanks so much for sponsoring this video
if you're not familiar with them
they are an online learning community
that has
thousands of classes for creative and
curious people which is hopefully you
watching right now
and their class topics range from
photography
design illustration freelancing coding
productivity
the list goes on and on and one class
i'm currently watching right now
which i'm really enjoying is called
youtube success
by marcus brownlee he's one of the top
youtube
creators on the platform and he has a
class
breaking down his process for making
youtube videos
how he prepares films edits and it's
really fascinating
and i think it could definitely appeal
to those who
want to grow a brand on youtube so i do
have a special offer
to my subscribers the first 1 000 people
to click the link
in the video description we'll get a one
month free trial
to skillshare so you can join the
platform and
start learning exploring and discovering
and with that let's get back to the
chess
so how you found playing white daniel
dubois playing black
i know the result is already spoiled but
i hope that won't ruin the fun
of uh of this game and
uh let's start with the first few moves
get ready for it get ready for it
it's staffer gambit time i'm so elated
to have
seen this played by especially by duboff
who's like one of the
most cool now even cooler super grand
masters
on the planet and i'm really curious
i'm actually curious about two things
here's whether howie fawn is even like
aware
that this opening has a name um i highly
doubt that she watches my content
especially given the move that she plays
next
uh i'm also curious if duboff has like
seen my videos and maybe got inspired
maybe saw the the jonathan schrantz
video on how he
takes down stockfish or at least draw
stockfish
from a stafford but what happened this
game is how you find to climb the gambit
instead of taking on c6 and putting
black to the test
she treated this like um more standard
petrov
and moved back to f3 now i should note
the main line is d6 minus three which is
just
standard theory but against the stafford
the only way to punish the gambit
especially at the highest level is to
accept it
and win a pawn which unfortunately
didn't happen this game
um i would have been really curious to
see how
play would unfold between two strong
grand masters
and i imagine djubov was somewhat
prepared especially in the
more critical tricky variations because
one one line that a lot of like strong
players play these days
is d3 bishop c5 bishop e2
after h5 c3 for a while this is
considered to be
like the refutation and like if white is
really well prepared
this is probably a good enough
refutation
but for players that maybe are just kind
of
stumbling into this is white even if
you're a strong gm
when knight g4 happens things can get
very very messy
and the key line is after d4 queen h4 g3
queen f6 i have a few videos on this
there's the jonathan tron's video which
i'll link below
and um it would have been really cool if
they went into this
however the game was actually a bit more
peaceful
because howie fawn declined the gamut
played knight f3
djubov wins back the pawn
d3 knight f6 d4
now black plays d5 and if we
observe the position you'll notice
that it's almost completely symmetrical
but black is a one
having an extra tempo white wasted time
moving the knight twice moving the
d-pawn twice
and it's black with uh the early opening
advantage because there's one extra
piece developed
and even though the position's kind of
symmetrical
it's black who is already slightly for
choice
now play unfolds pretty naturally bishop
d3 bishop d6
gasling castling and pawn c3
very standard move there's cases where
if black had
like one more tempo knight b4 could be
played
so after c3 it's now up to black to
figure out
how to um how to proceed
kind of leaving the opening entering the
middle game
and the most natural move here that i
think most people would play
is bishop to g4 just pinning the knight
but i really like the move that dubois
plays the move is very active but it's
also prophylactic
it's to play knight e4 and the point
obviously we're improving the knight
we're potentially preparing f5 to get a
very nice bind in the center
kind of like a stonewall setup but on
top of this
we're leaving white's dark square bishop
without an active place to develop to
because now bishop g5
is just out of the question so is bishop
f4
and these two squares on
e3 and d2 don't seem too attractive
so an 84 is a really nice idea
especially if black can get away with it
right away
and of course if white tries to attack
it with rookie 1 or knight d2
black can reinforce it in a variety of
ways
so after 94 howie fawn tried to
undermine black center as quickly as
possible
by playing pawn c4 which
in some sense is wasting even more time
like if we look at how he finds opening
in the first 10 moves she's moved the
the kingside knight one two three times
and she's moved both the d and c
pawn twice of course this move is uh
is somewhat justified because the
deepon's undefended and the d-pawn the
only thing
defending the knight so white is using
initiative here
but this does give dubov an opportunity
to be aggressive next move being knight
b4 which is really nice and this is one
of the reasons why c3 was played earlier
to prevent knight b4
but now black can get away with this and
is really just going after the bishop
pair
so if white takes black can take take
and even though blocks temporarily down
the pawn after you move like bishop f5
black has full initiative d pawns are
going to be weak
and uh knight g3 is also a threat here
so for that reason howie fawn
retreated the bishop yeah began moving
the same piece twice in the opening so
defying a lot of opening principles
and now dubai plays bishop f5 so
it's move 11.
black has all the minor pieces developed
and light just has
the kingside develop hasn't touched
anything on the queen side
so opening battle has clearly gone to
black
and i guess this is what can happen if
you decline the staff or gambit and you
play very timidly
from the black perspective if you can
play actively develop
rapidly then you can get a nice opening
position
without even needing to gambit so how
efaun continues plays a3
do bob retreats knight c3 there is some
trade
and now h6 another prophylactic move
um h6 has perhaps a few reasons of
course prevents anything
from coming to g5 white had some plan
of after the trade of knights to play
this this
this and have some purpose in life for
the dark spray bishop
game continues bishop d3 straight on c3
and now queen f6 so black is still
playing actively
um just improving further connecting the
rooks
getting ready to bring the rooks into
the center rook b1 was played
on b6 and for people who are
maybe more experienced in different
types of openings
this structure is actually very
reminiscent
of a four night scotch but reverse
and this pawn b6 move is really nice
because it undermines the rook
in some cases prepares knight a5
and then the eventual positional break
with pawn c5
so things are going to get positional uh
though hau yifan played a
kind of very active move rook b5 hitting
the bishop
on the fifth rank djubov was provoked to
trade
and after the trade on d3 dubai very
simply aligns the rook
with the queen and this is very common
in chess especially
going into the middle game if you're not
sure where to put your rooks
sometimes it's nice to put your rook on
the same file
as your opponent's queen in this case
the d file
is half open for black so um
there there's some potential for tactics
further down the road
and of course jubob is preparing to put
other rook
on the fully open e file
so here the game continues pawn a4 rook
fe-8
black is fully optimizing and now
here comes a nice positional maneuver
starting with knight e7
and here dubov is making way for the c
pawn to advance but also preparing the
knight
to come to perhaps a more active square
like f5
or eventually d5 or maybe even knight g6
to f4
so very flexible move how efon plays a
bit slowly here
starts with h3 and now c5
of course dreaming of getting rid of the
d-pawn
now of course a strong grandmaster like
hauifan would not
not blunder like this but if white takes
on c5
black would be very happy to respond
with bishop h2 oh no my bishop
but oh no your queen so
these sort of tactics are very abundant
whenever the
rook is aligned with the white queen
like this so in some sense the d-pawn is
pinned
because of the x-ray here how iphone
goes for a pawn break of her own
a5 of course dubov has a nice sort of
mini pawn chain on the queen side and a5
is one way to try and destroy the pawn
chain
so dubov just kind of ignores the break
and goes for knight d5
which is a very multi-purpose square for
the knight crushing the bishop
pressuring the c pawn ideas of this hit
the queen
ideas of this hit the rook really nice
move there
fabifan takes takes and now
plays bishop d2 so preserving your
bishop
perhaps considering ideas of c4 at some
point
uh but dubois strikes with knight to
c7 and at first
this move looks like a blunder because
what's defending the pawn
the knight was just defending the pawn
but now the knight's on c7
and i can imagine dubov playing this
move and saying oh no my pawn
but this pawn would be poisonous for the
same reason
that there were tactics on the d-file
there's also tactics on the sixth rank
and bishop h2
in this case is winning the exchange
after it takes we can take the rook
so it's very important in chess to
realize what's aligned with what
especially when there's a possible check
or discovery in the position
that you're not falling victim to the
geometry
of the position now of course how you
fondan take the poison pawn
retreats to rook all the way to b1 and
the game continues
dubov expanding on the queen side and b5
is a really nice
move especially from a positional
standpoint
and i do want to give kind of a general
rule which applies to just so many types
of positions
whenever both sides have a single bishop
of the same color
in this case both sides have a dark spot
bishop
the general plan should be to place your
pawns
on the opposite collar of that bishop so
both sides in this position
should be trying to fix their pawns on
light squares
and also fix her opponent's pawns on
dark squares b5 is a step forward
in this direction for dubov he wants to
soon play c4 and get the pawns
complementing the bishop instead of just
getting in the way of
of his own bishop and if c4 is played
these pawns would be fixed on dark
squares and this bishop would be
even more sad and that's basically what
happened
after rook fe1 c4 queen c2
the structure is now fixed even though
black's not so much better
black has a pleasant advantage just
because
of the superior minor piece and the
potential to exploit these uh
especially the c3 pawn later on
now the next move from dubov i think
illustrates some
deeper end game understanding and it's a
very committal move
between g6 which i don't think too many
players would
even consider playing just because it
offers
fight to take and destroy black's
structure just have double the ugly
double g
pawns but the reason for playing this
move is that after takes
takes okay another train on e8
black is still the one pressing for an
advantage
and duval understood that the resulting
end game is actually really easy to play
for black
eventually the knight is going to have a
square the rook's already controlling
the e
file but also has potential to use a
file
and there's always looming possibilities
of b4 maybe not right now
but later white has to be on constant
watch
and on top of all of this
the knights on f3 and the bishop on d2
are just not effective and there's so
much more potential for blacks
bishop and knight in this position so
how you fun continues
plays king f1 king of seven
and now how you fun plays a really kind
of mysterious
move which is interesting pawn d5
attempting to trade the d-pawn for the
b-pawn
so if knight takes d5 rook b5 white
would be fine here
with initiative against the knight and a
square for the nylon d4
but this didn't happen dubov calmly
plays rook b8
and now white's in the predicament this
pawn is now
over defended and the knight can
mobilize
take the pawn and just win it for free
and that's basically what ended up
happening after knight d4
rook b7 bishop e3 king e8
knight c6 duboff took on d5
black is up a pawn now in hindsight
how you find probably just should have
left her knight on d4
pressuring b5 and it probably would have
been more of a challenge for black to
win the pawn maybe would have had to
eventually trade off
bishop for knights and then lock the
king in
but knight c6 definitely made doubt's
life
a bit easier and after it takes bishop
d4
in d7 it's black whose advantage
is beginning to grow knight a5 was
played hitting the rook
rook b8 and here it looks like white can
win the pawn back
with bishop takes g7 however
this would be yet another poison pawn
and do bob is very sly in like creating
these situations where it looks like he
has something hanging but
doesn't actually and hear the tactics uh
just go in blocks favor black would have
the very nice move bishop c7
and white's knight is just trapped if
rookie won
and rook 8 and white's losing material
and black would be on the road to
winning this game
so how eufaun probably realized that
went for bishop to
a7 hitting the rook trying to
deflect the rook from defending the pawn
however knight takes c3 very timely
counter-attack winning another pawn
hitting the rook and white is now
just really suffering here roxy one was
played hitting the knight
and for a moment it looks like okay
black has some
some issues to to deal with
but all the issues are resolved very
simply with rook
288 counter-attacking the bishop also
skewing the bishop in the night
and here's where things really go in box
favor after bishop d4
knight a2 hitting the rook the knight is
still hanging
white is losing a piece after okay
getting two pawns for it
but it's not gonna be enough bishop f8
defending the g7 pawn
and black is up a clean piece here a few
more moves were played
and i should show the ending ending is
nice after bishop g7
trying to exploit the fact that the
bishop
was defending two things at once
duval responds with knight to d5
creating now two threats of course
threatening to take the bishop
but also threaten the fork we can see by
the time stamps here
how you find had 20 seconds i think
took the bishop in panic and just got
forked
and then resigned and
that's a game it was actually a very
positional game
from what one might expect
a stafford to offer but
it was a very satisfying game for duboff
and for me
nonetheless given that uh
staffer gambit was effective against a
strong grandmaster
even though it wasn't accepted we saw
that
when white declined the gambit and
wasted some time in the opening black
was really the one
in control for most of the game so
i hope people enjoy that i hope people
are inspired
even though i know stafford is
objectively dubious
it could still be played against
opponents who maybe aren't the most
prepared
and if you have any questions leave them
below
i do get staffer gabby questions on a
pretty regular basis
so maybe at some point i'll have to make
a video just addressing
stafford hand questions from viewers so
stay tuned make sure you hit the
subscribe button
and i'll see you in the next video